hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Swedish drama film called
The 100 year old man who climbed out the
window and disappeared spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the protagonist of the movie is a 99
year old man named Alan Carlson he lives
in a remote Swedish village with his pet
cat and the two appear to be very close
unfortunately one day the cat sneaks
outside into the snow where it is
attacked and killed by a wolf Alan has
devastated that the only friend in his
life is gone so he starts plotting
Revenge he installs some Dynamite out in
the snow and then baits the fox with
some sausages when the poor animal comes
near it is blown to pieces this makes
the old man happy for a while but later
he is punished for his Shenanigans Alan
is transferred to a retirement home
where he will have to live the rest of
his life weeks pass but Alan doesn't get
used to the place he longs to go outside
and feel the fresh air again to wire up
some explosives and evaporate wild
animals but the authorities don't allow
him to Fed Up Alan escapes the
retirement home through a window right
on his 100th birthday he doesn't have
any relatives to contact act or a plan
to execute but he is happy to finally be
outside after wandering the streets for
a while he arrives at a bus station he
then brings out some coins and asks the
receptionist to provide him tickets for
the next bus unfortunately the money is
not enough so the receptionist suggests
he go to a nearby town called Byron he
explains that it is a desolate place
with only one inhabitant in it but Alan
who is fed up with the retirement home
immediately buys the ticket just then a
grumpy looking gang member named Bolton
arrives there dragging a large suitcase
with him he goes straight inside the
bathroom but the suitcase doesn't fit so
he orders Alan to look after it until he
comes back the old man agrees but soon
after when his bus arrives he gets on it
with the suitcase this is how old people
commit theft if you catch them in the
ACT they just say what year is it after
a while the bus departs the station and
Alan starts narrating about his
childhood when he was a young boy his
father invented rubber protection and
tried to endorse it to the general
public however the Swedish Monarch he
took this as an act of blasphemy and
imprisoned him this guy's trying to make
sex feel bad kill him later they
executed oh they executed him with the
help of the firing squad Alan remembers
the day when some officials came to his
house and revealed about his father's
death they had brought along some of his
belongings which were mostly explosives
and ornaments although his mother wept
profusely Alan didn't give a single
Frick because his father was always
absent from his life rather he started
experimenting with the explosives and
quickly made it his hobby some years
later his mother also passed away after
a lengthy battle with cancer now Alan
was completely alone with no relatives
or friends to support him just bombs
however he still didn't care Allen
continued his hobby of blowing things up
and gradually got better at it ironic
that his father's life's mission was to
stop anything from blowing in the
present he arrives at B Ranch which is a
small town in the middle of nowhere when
the station manager Julius sees Alan
wandering around with a large suitcase
he inquires if everything is fine the
latter explains that he just wants to
explore the world as much as he can
before passing away hearing this Julius
invites him to his house and offers him
some food at this point the officials at
the retirement home have also found out
about Alan's disappearance and a
medium-scale search operation led by
detective Aaronson has been put in place
elsewhere we see that Bolton has beaten
up the receptionist and the two are
currently on their way to be Ranch the
angry gang member is adamant on
retrieving his suitcase indicating that
something very valuable is kept inside
it after a while he makes it to be
wrench and immediately heads inside the
only house present there Bolton finds
Julius in the kitchen and starts
assaulting him to get information on his
suitcase fortunately Allen arrives from
behind and knocks him out with a strike
to his head the two oldies then drag his
body and lock him inside a freezing unit
in the next scene Alan and Julius decide
to open the suitcase to see what's
actually inside it to their shock it is
loads and loads
despite their old age the two are
blinded by the money and decide to keep
it for themselves that night they
celebrate their success over drinks
unfortunately the next morning they
realized that Bolton is still locked up
in the freezer Julius rushes to check on
him but when he opens the door the gang
member is already dead this upsets the
oldies as an innocent man passed away
due to their negligence however for Alan
this is not the first time he has killed
someone decades back when he was still a
teenager he accidentally blew up a
merchant while testing his new
explosives as a result he was confined
to a mental Asylum where he had to live
for 30 years moreover before Allen was
released he was neutered as the
officials believed his offspring would
also be a menace to society Allen
wandered around the city until he found
a job at a cannon Factory if I can't
shoot loads I may as well shoot balls
there he met a Spanish revolutionist
named Esteban and started learning about
politics as the days passed they became
good friends and Esteban eventually
convinced Alan to join the fight against
the dictatorship in Spain the two
traveled to Madrid where they planned to
kill General Franco however on the very
first day Esteban got killed because of
his talkative nature this didn't
intimidate Alan now and he continued
doing what he did best blowing things up
he became a very important part of the
Revolution and helped his group win
several battles but one day while he was
trying to set off some explosives he
suddenly quit and decided to return to
Sweden on his way back he stopped a car
to ask for a lift and at the same time a
large explosion took place nearby to his
surprise the person in the car was none
other than General Franco he regarded
Alan a hero for saving his life so to
return the favor General Franco held a
luxurious party in Allen's honor and
even gifted him with an extremely rare
pistol unlike you this doesn't fire
blanks back in the present the oldies
transport Bolton's body in a wagon and
dump it into a box which is destined for
Djibouti meanwhile the receptionist from
early earlier goes to the police station
and informs detective Aaronson about the
old man and Bolton he also reveals that
they are currently in beer inch hearing
this the detective immediately sets off
for the town he arrives there shortly
after and looks for Clues inside the
house when he finds nothing he goes to a
nearby radio station and announces that
a 100 year old man has gone missing if
anyone is able to find out about his
whereabouts they will be rewarded
handsomely elsewhere we are introduced
to a ferocious looking guy called Gadot
he is revealed to be the leader of the
same gang Bolton used to be a part of
Gideon is currently on house arrest
because of a crime he committed recently
unfortunately for him the suitcase was
supposed to be delivered to one of his
clients now he has 24 hours to find it
and if he doesn't he will be executed he
better get on with it on the other hand
as Julius and Alan are on their way back
home they have a sudden change of mind
and decide to go somewhere else so they
approach an innocent looking guy named
Benny and ask him for a ride the latter
agrees and asks where do you want me to
drop you off to which the Goldie's reply
wherever you're going he this slightly
confuses Benny but he doesn't ask
anything and starts driving after a
while they pull over at a gas station to
freshen up unfortunately Benny notices
Alan's missing posters and confronts him
about it the old man tries to lie his
way out of the situation but to no avail
he's the only guy within a bajillion
miles he looks that old hence he
reluctantly coughs up the entire truth
about how they killed a man and how they
have millions in cash Julius then asks
Benny to be a part of their team and
drive them around the country in
exchange he will be given an equal share
of the money without thinking twice
Benny accepts following this the movie
goes into another flashback Alan sold
the pistol given to him by Franco in
exchange for a work permit to America
initially he worked as a construction
worker but then using his vast knowledge
of explosives he started mingling with
renowned scientists like Oppenheimer he
even helped them solve a crucial problem
in the Manhattan Project the largest
nuclear bomb at that time soon Alan
became a popular figure in the states so
much so that even the vice president
invited him for dinner several years
later Allen returned to Sweden he was
considered a hero by many for his
contribution to Nuclear Physics one day
while he was in a meeting with some
Swedish diplomats he met a Russian
scientist named Popov because of their
shared interest in explosives they
quickly became friends and Popov invited
Alan to come to Russia with him on his
first day in Moscow Allen had a meeting
with Stalin the latter asked him to
reveal everything about the Manhattan
Project but Alan refused as a result he
was sent to the gulag where he met
Albert Einstein's timid twin brother
Herbert the two plotted for an entire
year and eventually escaped the place by
blowing it apart completely I'm
beginning to suspect this movie's not
true in the present Benny's car runs out
of gas so they are forced to stop at a
roadside Farm the owner Gunilla offers
to provide them with shelter for the
night but only if they pay her a good
amount hearing this the trio starts
laughing as money is definitely not a
problem for them after a while gunila
introduces the them to her pet elephant
which lives in a nearby shed days pass
and the three continue living in the
house Gunilla also doesn't order them to
leave because she has finally found some
good friends unfortunately one day a
gang member finds their location after
spotting Allen nearby he slowly
approaches the residents with a gun in
hand and when everyone is distracted he
grabs Alan from behind the gang member
then threatens the others to bring out
his suitcase if they don't want to see
the old man dead reluctantly Benny heads
inside and retrieves the bag but just as
the gang member is about to flee Gunilla
arrives with a weapon of her own this
scares the gang member and in a state of
panic he slips and falls right under the
large elephant unfortunately the poor
animal becomes terrified and sits on top
of the gang member killing him instantly
Dumbo just delivered that bum hoe after
the incident the man finally come clean
about the money and offer an equal share
to ganila as well in exchange she will
have to help them dispose of the body
elsewhere gadan has become rest
because two of his gang members are not
responding to his calls so with pressure
mounting he decides to break his ankle
device and head out to look for the
suitcase himself once again the movie
goes into a flashback Allen became an
agent for the CIA soon he was approached
by the Soviet Secret intelligence group
the KGB as both the parties offered him
good compensation Allen became a double
agent his daily routine consisted of
leaking the American secret information
to the Soviets and vice versa however
despite years of being a snitch he was
never caught back in the present the
group disposes of the gang member's body
and decides to leave the residence as it
is not safe anymore so ganila brings out
her truck which has enough room to
adjust the elephant as well they soon
hit the road and proceed to another city
but on the way godon finds them he stops
his car in front of them and attempts to
shoot the driver but this only results
in a horrible crash in the aftermath
gadan is left seriously injured so the
group tends to his injuries and takes
him in the truck they then resume their
journey and and head to a nearby
airstrip it turns out that Allen has
arranged a getaway airplane for them
using one of his past contacts a few
hours later gadan finally awakens but he
has no recollection of who he is or how
he got there so he remains calm and
decides to continue traveling with the
guys that evening they finally arrive at
their destination where they are picked
up by Alan's contact even the elephant
is adjusted inside the airplane and soon
they take off hoping for a better life
in the final scene the group arrives in
Bali it turns out that this was Alan's
plan all along ever since he laid hands
on the suitcase he wanted to spend the
rest of his days in the sunny skies of
Bali Benny and ganila get engaged while
gdan leaves his criminal past behind and
starts living a good life as for the
elephant it can now finally roam around
the Lush forests and golden beaches
without being bothered by anyone Dumbo's
getting that sun for Sho subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watch
teaching